[Music]
in spoiler alert news well we just had a
big spoiler on the episode that we did
on Game of Thrones jock who watched that
Sarah Hart oh actually his name's a
hubby hubby and then a heart all the
computer seems help you my phone too but
not the heart
so now he knows I had a heart okay mines
headache it has that that emoji with
them submitted by Nick Fury that guy's
like carrot cake sounds familiar who is
that marvel's Narwhal
what the super power is really smart a
man beat up his coworker for revealing
Avengers end game spoilers I've heard of
a lot of people getting beat up for this
there's some people that need an
ass-kicking cuz they like thrive off of
just giving you spoilers yeah and
they're [ __ ] out and they should get
the ask no do you know what happened and
freakin the the whole game of Thrones
[ __ ] right literally when the episode
ended everybody started uploading
spoilers and I'm like why you guys are
[ __ ] [ __ ] like if you enjoyed the
episode that much why would you do that
and you know if we want to go viral yeah
it's it's what it is is like people like
to be that source of I knew at first
before you did
yeah that's they get like biggest
[ __ ] to block that and they wanted
but burst in your bubble that and they
also are like well I'm part of the cool
crowd like I know it was just I was kind
of like hell you guys me such as well at
least give it one day you know give it a
day at least I would just block fools
then that's why on Sunday I don't go on
wow that's serious cuz I know that once
I open some [ __ ] up something's gonna
pop up and be me yeah I was so scared of
like the whole after 5 p.m.
don't do it see I'm gonna the weekend
because of the end cuz of endgame you're
like I don't want to know I'm so [ __ ]
glad nothing spoiled it my friends were
the best though the way they tweeted me
when I was watching like Game of Thrones
gonna spoil [ __ ] they were just like
just wait til this happens it's just
wait I was like these has a great that's
time I would never spoil a movie for
anybody but if I was one of those people
here's how I would do it I would find
out the most trending topic not endgame
put like something else
then I wouldn't like title my video that
and make it like the thumbnail look like
that so people are gonna click on it and
then I would Rick roll them with a
spoiler that's dope I'm gonna do that
never do that
you should do that I would never own lis
reason why I haven't watched endgame yet
is because it's [ __ ] three hours yeah
it's a little bit I'm like I'd three
hours it's [ __ ] 302 many hours should
be that long though because this is
literally 11 franchises 21 films 11
years of build-up to this flat that's
what I'm saying like yeah I just don't I
feel like there's gonna be a lot of
parts that's just based on nostalgia and
then like you know trying to get you to
cry you haven't seen yet no for three
hours
nah he didn't plan that out what they
mean you watch Titanic I have to be sick
again for me to watch Titanic I watch
Titanic just for the CG that's hilarious
then what the Wall Street three hours to
something about two hours is two hours a
lot of a lot of those don't feel like
three hours though that's three episodes
of Game of Thrones man are you crazy
I know everything that happens though
you do how do you know same I haven't
seen it but I know everything that
happens and I'm not gonna watch it like
it's just not my thing
yeah and I've just been so behind that
I'm like I just tell me what happened
sign our video by the time I watch it
I'll probably forget everything it would
be like a year from now I want to watch
this though you should go watch it at
our house in our house we have gotten
every single Marvel movie so all 21
films will - - the most recent ones I
kept in Marvel and the other one well
you don't we haven't bought those yet
what about venom but that's not it's
Marvel MCU though M&M sauce yeah we know
venom just like him it was a stupid
you got in your head forget it sounds
like that I don't like that sign either
it's like the worst song ever mm what is
that from the venom movie yeah I guess
Eminem did the venom song you don't like
no I didn't like basically his whole
encore CD and like a lot of relapse
that's cool blindly following no I got
opinions still Bobby Holland bastard
I've never missed an album released
that's pretty [ __ ] good that's what
you call a fan dude yeah even when he
surprised dropped an album I was there
immediately within 5 hours no as soon as
like he Instagram notification like
there's Eminem do like Botox and stuff I
think so dude oh really he looks like a
little Japanese girl skin is nice and
his nose is all perky and pretty and
look that's from City he doesn't have
like what where's all the crazy stuff
like yeah I forget that he's like almost
50 yeah damn yeah do you see his
daughter already went to [ __ ] prom
and she's in college now yeah what
Hayley I think she's out of college oh
my god
yeah she's like 21 or something she was
like 5 when she used to rap about her
yeah dude she was born on Christmas in
1995 Oh God
95 yeah she's like 25 then what the [ __ ]
yeah that's a like a long time she catch
up to me she could be on JK news okay
I'm she's so cute and Sheila J has like
good Instagram like influencer photos
and she keeps she keeps posting
regularly
oh dude mitt I've been like following I
mean look trying to look up a lot of
like aesthetic like Instagram stuff yeah
because I want to feel my feet which is
prettier stuff yes I've been unfollowing
a lot of people follow Haley Jade yeah
so I thought I've been following some of
these people and I kind of wonder what
these people do for a living because
there's just one girl that I fall I
can't remember her name but she's just I
was like you're like in a different
country she's a hooker
has to be
they have private accounts there's
absolute she's not a travel blogger
she's a travel blogger but she
definitely had either that way she comes
from a lot of money because there's no
way with her following but though we
travel bloggers they can have like a
small following I can like get all these
deals because they don't really get paid
so they get free [ __ ] yeah they get free
hotel room stay free like flights and
stuff but they don't really get paid but
you're still not walking around in
[ __ ] Jimmy Choos and [ __ ] Fendi
bags and stuff like that though because
if you're getting you know sure whatever
you're still not walking around with the
$10,000 bags I'm like oh what the [ __ ]
you have to comfort if you have like 30k
followers right and you're in like your
interactions like 400 likes per photo
there's no [ __ ] way dude and it's
kind of like I just thought about it I
was like okay it must be nice to have
money cuz I you this is literally what
it is to have freedom yeah you could
just be it's almost like you have to
have money to make money because in
order for her to have that type of
aesthetic she has to bring a
photographer around have all this great
equipment and she had she started from
Jodi has a huge head start compared to
everybody else so I was like that's like
that in every industry oh especially
entertainment that's true
think of like you had money and you went
into the entertainment industry you
could immediately make the first movie
you wanted to make out of your head you
know who the [ __ ] that is that kid when
we first met ya know we're right we were
our first thing that we shot with them
he already rented the same warehouse
they shot inception and matrix at dam
and then then that was just location one
location two he rented out ranch the
ballroom of the ballroom of a hotel so
for a sketch she was dropping 10 G's per
episode I'm like now was before vine
even yeah this is like he had like 500
followers yeah yeah I remember that I
met him during that time too and he was
like I'm stockpiling my sketches right
now and I'm like with what money I think
it's part of like Jamaican royalty or
something that's well we just making up
[ __ ] about now no I think I think it's
the President or some sort of diplomat I
think his mom was like a diplomat I
heard that they they made
I heard that they gave money because
this parents are accountants and
financial advisors or something like
that that makes more sense I also heard
that he's related to Black Panther yeah
that's what I heard welcome bring it
back to Marvel okay so a Texas man that
like it's being reported that he got his
ass beat for revealing a spoiler [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude a lot of quick got beat up
though I read an article about like
someone that spoiled it in like the
crowd of the people standing in line to
go see them that was what people are
doing for Harry Potter I love that [ __ ]
that was so funny but he got his ass
beat wait I talked about the one in Asia
he can't bite of in Asia I thought you
were gonna talk about the one in Asia
like that's another one they were coming
out of a screen II he was coming out of
a screening and people were waiting in
line to go in and he just ruined
everything for them and he got his ass
beat I'm very smart because that would
have made sense maybe ten years ago
where Marvel and comic-book stuff was
really for geeks yeah now everybody
watches it so there's some [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] homie [ __ ] it ask me everybody
loves Marvel now yeah you see their
bottom whether like Dumbledore dies and
you see this yeah one of the funniest
things ever I didn't see that but the
one that you're talking about is in Hong
Kong and they're saying that that one
might not be true because the cops are
like well we didn't get any reports
because so for that one they're saying
that this man right like coming outside
of the theater like walking what an
idiot
yeah I would have did it in the car so
you could drive away we would never
spoil but if we did we'd be in a car I
bet you he wasn't even trying to spoil
it he was just talking to his friend
about all these things that are spoiling
it and he's talking so [ __ ] loud that
everyone can know this dude he shouted
it to the crowd oh I'm speaking about in
China cuz you know how like in Hong Kong
they like to talk really loud that's so
he's probably was just talking to his
friend really laughs oh my god that time
would this happen and whatever I don't
like hey what the [ __ ] man
is that what happened with the co-worker
situation uh well yeah so they're just
saying that there was this some of this
assaults at a Domino's Pizza and delino
Floyd so it was like a co-worker
altercation and so he just revealed a
plot point and then that's when he got
it yeah it's pretty big no but cuz it
tension matters that's true I think so
yeah
if you're trying to be a dick like the
guy that purposely ruined it for the
Harry Potter kids but there's another
really popular or like this viral or are
you going around with Avengers with the
endgame so they're saying that there was
a 21 year old girl from China she had to
be taken to the hospital because she was
crying so much as she was
hyperventilating she was crying in the
movie again this movie it makes you cry
like it makes you cry yeah but if my kid
was hyperventilate from cry all day with
one year old oh I would just know that
person 21 year old yeah so she had to go
be taken to the hospital and they gave
her ass people who aren't real oh you
know red though you're gonna tell me you
didn't Crying Game of Thrones mmm which
part like at all no not one
I watched it too fast for me to cry but
even til there's like right now when I
saw episode 2 I liked eyeball but if you
cry more to for it season 8 episode 2
like when like Brienne no I did not so
if you cry oh then it you do in real
life you got problem sure I mean that no
yeah if spider-man falls on the ground
and you're balling your grandma dies it
you don't care you got problems because
I'm not laughing I got problems there
yeah because I'm not we know I'm gonna
do that I'm not saying is ridiculous she
cried in the movie I'm saying the amount
of tears is crazy because I cried yeah
all the time but she's over here
yeah that hyperventilating is in
phonetics though we did just recently
read up on censorship laws in China and
things that are too emotionally like
arousing or whatever too much is is also
censored so they might just have a more
like milder oh so they're way more
sensitive just yeah see so yeah
[Music]